jean-paul sartre splay no exit is one of
the classics of existential literature
and what's going on in there is he's
illustrating using these three main
characters who we'll talk about in a
moment some of the the main themes
having to do with the nature of the
human person and our relations with
other people and about whether in fact
we can ever be happy one of the things
that you should ask about this play and
it's sort of an open question is whether
he's attempting to depict the human
condition as such or whether this really
is only the bad people that that this
sort of thing would happen to and the
answer seems to be leaning towards the
side this is the human condition of such
just set in a particularly crystallized
manner that allows us to see its
features most most clearly it's as far
as plays go something that that very
much fits the classical unities you know
time setting the characters themselves
in a certain respect or unities is
unlike other plays in which characters
might actually develop there's not a lot
of development going on there's just
revelation of who these people are and
it is set in such a way as to make it
impossible for these characters not to
engage each other so let's look at the
characters first and we're gonna we're
going to look at these in greater detail
and going over some of the key passages
but first we want to you know get the
three actually set up so at the
beginning there's actually what we could
call a ancillary character the valet who
Mayor may or may not be be one of the
devil's certainly works there it's not
part of management as he says and he
escorts garça into this this room and
garça is a newspaperman from Rio de
Janeiro in Brazil he is a pacifist
another thing that we can say about him
that gets
ille through this is he's also a
womanizer he has interesting
relationships with with his wife that
will explore another thing that you can
say about him from the very beginning is
that he's introspective he is concerned
with how he thinks of himself and how
other people think of him as as well
then we have Annette she's the next
character to come in again escorted by
the valet and she is a postal clerk
she's a lesbian and she describes
herself in other people's words but in
words that also seem to fit her own self
conception as a damned [ __ ] and she
will talk about her her cruelty as a
matter of fact one of the first things
that she she says that that's you know
in the sort of long discourse at the
beginning is that she knows what
torturers look like because she has seen
her own face in the mirror then third we
have a stone and Estelle has died very
recently
she's also younger than these other two
she's a person who came from the lower
class or maybe a lower middle-class
married into the upper class kind of a
common phenomena in sart's own time as
well as you know still in the present
and she seems very superficial at the
beginning it turns out that there is
some depth to her but it's the more that
we go into it the less you're gonna like
it so these three are set up with each
other in a certain way each of them
represents a personality type and as is
a sadist but not the kind of status to
you know goes about getting people that
they can subject to their own their own
whims and and wills
in a systematic way just the kind of
person who picks constantly Garcia has
somebody who's in delusion about his own
statuses as a man Estelle is is you
might say coquettish she constantly
needs other people to be affirming her
own value and those other people need to
be met and so putting these three
together sets up a dynamic an unstable
dynamic but a dynamic that's always
guaranteed to pan out for for the worse
enough though to give them hope at
certain points yeah and it's interesting
we see this arise at several different
points the possibility of there being a
solution
most often proposed by Garza at one
point proposed by an as I suppose you
could see what Estelle is proposing and
at a certain point is being a kind of
solution as well and all of these come
come crashing down and they all come
crashing down because of who these
people are and the fact that they can't
escape each other so this is a good
place to talk about the setting and I
put timelessness there rather than
eternity because these characters do
exist in time but it's a time that
simply can't end and it's a time where
things begin to lose their there there's
a slippage that's occurring between the
time of this place and the time of the
world that we know there are put into a
drawing-room in Second Empire style
something that we probably most of us
can't relate to as a description just
think about really I suppose for
imagining this any sort of gauche
you know kitschy kind of kind of
environment would work and a
drawing-room was where you would you
would meet together and talk and you
know do that sort of thing so it's not a
room set up for dinner it's not a room
set up for putting on your makeup it's
not a room set up for you know dancing
or anything like that it was very common
to have drawing rooms in in old
fashioned houses
this is where you might actually meet
your guests and sit and talk for a while
and in many places they would be
decorated in a rather overbearing kind
kind of style and this one seems to be
like this so that's what the place is
like there's actually what you know I
think are saying is the word an
abomination there's an abomination on
the mantelpiece which is some brass
thing much more interesting is the fact
that these characters not only can they
not leave the room although we'll see
that there is one opportunity for that
they can't sleep and they can't cry
these are things that the dead no longer
can do as a matter of fact our sound
observes that they don't even have
eyelids they're not able to blink
they're not able to close their eyes
they're not able to change their
condition in any way and the crying
means that they're unable to make a kind
of progress in in emotional terms in
relational terms because to cry means to
actually allow there to be some sort of
outward sign of the anguish or regret or
realization with that they may all get
there and each one of them is expecting
hell to be hellish they expect burning
coals and pincers and racks and stuff
like like that you know the sort of
things that are depicted in cartoons and
in old paintings or you know say in
traditional writings about Helmick say
Dante's Inferno and they're all
surprised to find out that there isn't
anything like that that they're just
going to be stuck in this room with each
other so the question that this is the
central preoccupation of the entire bar
with the entire play what makes it help
what makes this particularly hellish and
the answer that's given at the very very
end is that hell is
other people now if you're kind of a
misanthropic person or somebody who's
been disappointed all the time or very
irritable or if you're caught in certain
circumstances if you're you know stuck
in in in a culture that is particularly
anti intellectual or anti artistic maybe
this would you know be something that
you could identify with right away and
there are passing times where because of
the situation that we're in you know
imagine getting onto a crowded subway
then you could think yeah hell is other
people
or dealing with all sorts of
unpleasantness coming from the needs
desires preoccupations of of others then
that makes sense but it is this
something that holds is start trying to
say that this is the case for everybody
at that point we want to ask the
question why why does tell other people
yeah if we look at the characters who
finally have this realization mouth by
garden bark by gar Sam but you know
Ascenta to buy the others we want to ask
why is this the case and I think that
it's worthwhile to reflect a bit on
traditional conceptions of Hell if we
get away from the fire and brimstone and
eternal physical tortures and we think
about other models of what hell consists
in a lot of theologians have framed Hell
in terms of separation from God yeah you
could say well that's you know maybe you
don't like God so maybe that's not so
bad what would be the problem with it
well in hell you are on your own if
you're cut off from God and you're cut
off from in some respects the rest of
the world you're entirely cast upon your
own resources
your own memories your relations with
other things and in hell you can't
change you can't grow now it's not like
purgatory is you know say Dante
portrayed it where you are gradually
purified of the stains of what you've
done wrong and you become a better
person once you're in hell you're stuck
with who you are for eternity and over
the course of eternity
whatever illusions you have about you
know the good person that you are or
that you you know didn't really mean to
do this over here or that you know if
things had just turned out differently
here your great intentions would have
been known all of that gets stripped
away from you and we see that happening
over the course of this play in
different ways with particularly with
Estelle and Garson and Nez in a certain
way is is somebody who doesn't hope that
end is already more accommodating
towards towards being in hell and we'll
see why so I think the next thing that
we want to do is look at each of these
three characters in turn and think about
the kind of person that they are that's
revealed in their discussion with these
these other people and what's really
noticeable about this is that really no
action no no significant action takes
place in here everything is taking place
through words the first character to to
scrutinise is this guy Joseph Garson a
Brazilian we assume that he's Brazilian
newspaperman meaning somebody who works
in the newspaper he might be reporter he
might be an editor all we know is that
he spends a lot of time at the office
and cares quite a bit about with the
people at the office think of him
he is also a pacifist and we don't
really know whether he's a pacifist just
by conviction or whether he is also
he's very preoccupied with whether he's
also a coward he's a husband and we're
gonna look at that very closely in a
moment and he talks about him as having
gotten his wife out of the gutter you
saved her you know the lowest of the
lower class he is also a womanizer and
these are things that we can say about
about him that he reveals over time
there's other things as well that we
would want to say that have to do with
his function within the play that also
show us you know who he is because
remember you can't change your character
once and he'll so something that you can
say about him is that he's rather
reflective and that he's he's concerned
with something like an absolute like you
know you could say that he wants to
exist in other people's eyes but he
wants to exist in a certain way he wants
to be seen as a tough guy and as a real
man and he also wants to be seen as
somebody who is worthy of love and we'll
get to that dynamic in a bit so let's
look at each of these in turn you know
quite a bit of the play he's talking
although the characters can see what's
going on in the world that they've left
yeah he is alternating between what's
going on at the newspaper office and
what's going on with his wife who is
trying to find out what's happened to
him he was shocked as a deserter by a
firing squad and they don't let his wife
know for some time and then they finally
give his his shirt to her full of bullet
holes and blood and that's how she finds
out so all of these things actually end
up getting tied together at least the
newspaperman pacifist and
and husband how so well it's because
he's a pacifist that when he is
conscripted he he leaves he flees he
gets on a train to go to Mexico where
his intention according to him is to
start a pacifist newspaper that's at
least what he's telling himself and what
he tells the his fellow residents in
hell for for a while but he's not quite
sure whether that truly was what was on
his mind or whether he's really just a
coward he gets caught and they bring him
back and they execute him by firing
squad and he says if I could just be
courageous at that moment and we don't
know exactly what he happens but he
doesn't show courage perhaps he you know
what's his pants or something along
those lines and then his life as his
wife is left in the lurch trying to you
know figure out what happened to to her
husband for for quite a while and he's
not particularly caring about you know
what has happened to his wife he seems
much more interested in whether he
really was a good man or whether he was
was a coward there's a set of passages
that are particularly revealing I think
where he talks about his relationship
with his wife
and he says why am I here it's not
because I was a deserter it's not
because I was a coward it's I'm here
because I treated my wife abominably
that's all for five years naturally
she's suffering still there she is the
moment I mentioned her I see her and he
goes through you know talking about how
how she's you know there without the
shirt and she's not crying and he says
no you can't shed a tear my love surely
he'll squeeze one out at last no you
can't manage it night after night I came
home blind drunk stinking of wine and
women she'd set up for me of course but
she never cried never
a word of reproach only her eyes spoke
big tragic eyes I don't regret anything
I must pay the price but I shan't whine
it's snowing on the street won't you cry
and he goes on with that and it now is
asked why did you hurt her like that I
remember it nas's herself kind of love
kinda sadist so it's not clear why she's
asking guys sent says it because it was
so easy a word was enough to make her
flinch
I'm fond of teasing I wait I watched and
waited and so what else did he do
there's there's another incident that he
brings up that shows you you know
womanizer he was here's something you
can get your teeth into I well I brought
a half-caste girl to stay in our house
my wife slept upstairs she must have
heard everything she was an early riser
and as I am the girl stayed in bed late
she served our us our morning coffee and
then NS says you brute and he says yes a
brute if you like but a well-beloved
brute so he he doesn't really have any
any regrets over what he thinks landed
him in hell and nobody ever actually
says yes this is exactly why you are
being sentenced it could be because he
was a coward it could be because he was
in what Sartre calls calls bad faith
this condition where a human being
essentially lies to themself and tells
them that there's something tells
themselves that there's something other
than they are usually something better
than they are that they're not
responsible for the kind of behavior
that they engage in the kind of person
that they've become that circumstances
forced it that they didn't have a choice
when it starts philosophy says we always
do have a choice and we have you can say
that for certain we have a duty to
actually explore who we are our
structures of motivation why we make the
decisions that we do and if we find
things in our self that are
reprehensible or unsavory to to try to
you know correct those if we if we can
Garr Stan doesn't do that instead he
keeps on you might say raising the
stakes he flees rather than going to war
he says it's because I'm a pacifist so
I'm really a hero I'm standing up for my
my values my my principles but then it
turns out maybe he isn't and he he ends
up you know asking later eyes showing
some some qualms and he's talking with
Estelle and we'll talk more about why
he's doing this he says here we go
he asked am i a coward and she says how
can I say don't be so unreasonable
darling I can't put myself in your skin
you must decide that for yourself that's
a very typically sorry--and thing each
of us has to figure out who we are and
what kind of person we are and he says I
can't decide now to not be able to
decide something like that Sartre would
say is in a certain way to try to it's a
choice to not make a choice it's it's a
choice to pretend like one can't make a
choice and Estelle says well you must
remember you must have had reasons for
acting as you did and he says yeah I had
reasons and she says well and then he
asked the key question were they the
real reasons yeah and she says don't
worry about all that and he says I
thought it all out I wanted to make a
stand but was that my real motive was
that what I was really doing and she
says fine trying to be honest with
yourself for once and he says do I
really need you to tell me that day and
night I paced myself from the window to
the door from the door to the window I
pried into my heart I sleuth myself like
a detective by the end of it I felt I'd
given my whole life to introspection
there was that reflectiveness damage
well but always I hark back to the one
thing certain that I had act as acted as
I did so motives are harder to figure
out we know what we in fact did and we
know what the effects of it were we
what the the choice in that moment was
said I'd taken that train to the
frontier but why why did I do that
finally I thought my death will settle
it if I face death courageously my go
color turned out that he didn't face
death courageously and now he's in Hell
still playing the same game of saying
maybe I can you know work this out in
some way so actually I'm not a coward
I'm actually a hero part of the reason
why it's hell for him is because the
other people make it impossible for that
to be the case particularly in Eze but
also a stealth each in their own way
foreign as she is ready to pick at him
and say you actually are a coward you're
just lying to yourself
Estelle in a certain way is even more
cruel by saying it doesn't matter to me
whether you're a coward not just whether
you kiss well so what it is that you're
really preoccupied with what your
self-image consistent I don't care about
that what I care about is what you mean
to me what you provide me garça is the
person at the end who will actually say
hell has other people and he is the one
who this is probably a key point that's
worth actually putting up here he is the
one who is constantly proposing
solutions so in a certain way he
represents a kind of hopefulness but a
hopefulness that is always going to be
disappointed and then like collapse in
on itself it doesn't have enough to
really see itself through and he'll
propose solution after solution after
solution and we'll look at those he also
comes to realize that they are caught in
this this as he puts it a spiderweb
where if one of them does something it
affects the others so that's this
character Joseph
next we have Annette Serrano and she's
the one character who early on realizes
the condition that they're in so in many
ways she's trading off between her and
Garson the the role of narrating what's
what's truly going on behind the scenes
for her it's just a suspicion and it
might come out of her her own character
and what she's projecting onto the world
because she is we're gonna rather
sadistic and that lens that lens to her
a certain you might say paranoia
expecting everybody else to be
persecuting her and turn what we can say
about her is that she is a post office
clerk in contrast to the the well off
Estelle she's a lesbian and this comes
out very very early on she was in this
relationship with this woman Florence
that we'll discuss in just a moment and
what Sartre does a particularly good job
in portraying with her is that when it
comes to to sexual desire she feels
desire for Estelle and there's there's
you know interesting ways in which this
is brought out without getting
pornographic or we're even really too
explicit but she also feels a kind of
disgust for Garcia and his mannish Ness
and gar sent by the way is the one who
Estelle who who in as desires she's
desiring herself and they almost get it
on in front of her and she's talking
about how how disgusting she's finding
it at the time by her own admission
she's cruel she's a torturer
she's sadistic she has this desire for
Estelle but you know
zyre for Estelle because she really
cares about Estelle perhaps not it
what's interesting about her desire is
that it carries through all the
revelations that Estelle makes about who
she is all of these all three of these
people realized that they are rotten to
the core to use their own words and yet
she still desires Estelle she has a
feeling for her and she is the one who
realizes their condition as opposed to
Garson who says you know I can i can use
all this time to sort of put my life in
order and Nazz will say well
everything's put in order for me there's
nothing for me to think about now the
only question is what am I going to do
with this eternity of time in front of
me let's look at a few passages that I
think are particularly important or
revelatory so as soon as she gets in the
room she thinks that Garr Stan is going
to be the torturer and gar SAS says you
know that's that's too comic for words
come on in have a good look at me and he
says now that we've broken the ice do
you really think I look like a torturer
by the way how does one recognize
torturers when one sees them evidently
you've got ideas on the subject Annette
says they look frightened and you might
say that's a flip comment on Sartre you
know it's an easy thing to throw in at a
time when torture was in fact going on
in many places it's sort of you know
typical thing that an intellectual would
say about that they don't they don't
really have guts he's not going there
with this garces's friend but how
ridiculous so whom should they be
frightened of their victims and a neces
laugh away but I know what I'm talking
about I will often watching my face in
the glass
yond there's nothing more said there but
what's being hinted at the the one who
is cruel to the other person
actually is worried about how the other
person is going to react how they're
perceiving them maybe they're even
shocked at what they do to the the other
person and what the other person endures
a little bit later on and nas's the one
who's willing to sort of call a spade a
spade and she says yes we are all
criminals murderers all three of us
we're in hell my pets they never make
mistakes and people aren't damned for
nothing Estelle doesn't want to hear
that she says stop for heaven's sake and
Annette says in hell damned souls that's
us all three and Estelle says keep quiet
I forbid you to use such disgusting
words why why talking about disgusting
words at that point meeting words that
we don't want to hear we don't want to
recognize the situation that we're in
and and as says a damn soul that's you
my little plaster st. and ditto our
friend here the noble pacifist we've had
her hour of pleasure haven't we there
have been people who burned their lives
out for our sake and we chuckled over it
we didn't appreciate the sacrifice that
was made notice that she's not just
saying that what's bad is that they had
other people burn their lives out for
their sake but that they chuckled over
it they didn't appreciate it they they
even you know in Garcia's case made
light of it so now we have to pay the
reckoning and then she says I understand
now I know why they've put us three
together this is a question that they're
they're concerned with throughout the
play in the early part and she says
you'll see how simple it is childishly
simple obviously there aren't any
physical torments and yet we're in hell
and no one will ever come here well stay
in this room together the three of us
forever and ever in short there's
someone absent here the official
torturer so she says it's obvious what
they're after an economy of manpower or
devil power if you prefer the same ideas
the cafeteria where customers serve
themselves just
what do you mean and and that says I
mean that each one of us will act as the
torture of the two others so she's
realized the the condition that they're
in she'll talk in other places about
each of them being trapped laid for the
others you know for example because she
desires Estelle Estelle is a trap for
her she can invest her her time her
attention even if she can muster it up
her love and by doing so she'll be
laying herself in for the greater
disappointment greater pain greater
humiliation and she says to to Garson
you know there's translate for you as
well each one of us has traps laid for
us here that will cause us to be
frustrated cause us to be humiliated
cause us to be confronted with with our
own condition who we are and we'll be
confronted with the fact that others are
actually seeing us as we are and not
happy with it that we can't so if we say
it very crude terms we can't put any BS
over them we can tell it to ourselves
but it won't work while they're in the
room she is the one who's probably the
most conscious of the presence of the
others
she tells Garson at a certain point that
you know even if you're quiet I can hear
you over there thinking this is what we
call intentionality in in philosophy and
phenomenology in particular and Sartre
is putting into nez's mouths a great
speech about intentionality you know
when we perceive that even if another
doesn't speak we can we can perceive
their attitudes we can perceive their
intentions and sometimes we can miss
perceive these but very often we can
sort of peer into them
at least to a certain depth sometimes
seeing things that they themselves are
unaware that they're projecting and Nazz
is painfully conscious of that she can't
get away from that now how did she end
up there here is her story she says why
am i down here well I was with some
people down there called a damn [ __ ]
dammed already so it's no surprise being
here she's very cynical she's unhelpful
she's despairing and then gar senses
that all you have the saying she says no
there was an affair with Florence a dead
man's tale with three corpses to it he
to start with then she and I so there's
no one left I have no one to worry about
it was a clean sweep
only that room I see it now and then
empty with the doors locked and then you
know she goes on and and and Garces says
did the man kill himself and she says he
no he had the guts for that still he had
every reason we let him a dog's life as
a matter of fact he was run over by a
tram a silly sort of end I was living
with them he was my cousin so what she's
done is she seduced her cousin's wife or
girlfriend and they're sort of you know
flaunting their their affair and in
front of him and you know apparently at
one time she was sort of okay with the
cousin but then she says I got sick of
him quite gradually all sorts of little
things got on my nerves for instance he
made a noise when he was drinking a kind
of gurgle trifles like that he was
rather pathetic really
vulnerable that shows you you know for n
as if you show weakness if you show
vulnerability she will go on the attack
because that's the kind of person that
she is she tells us this a little bit
later she says when I see him cruel I
mean I can't get out without making
people suffer like a live coal alive :
others hearts when I when I'm alone I
flick her out for six months I flamed
away in her heart till there
is nothing but a cinder one night she
got up and turned down the gas while I
was asleep
then she crept back into bed so now you
know so they they got her cousin to get
you know go out onto the street and get
run over by a passing tram and then she
just picked and picked and picked at her
lover until her lover killed both of
them
by by turning on the gas and going to
bed so an des this is what what she
thinks got her down in hell but she
thinks that she was ready for hell to
begin with because of the kind of person
that she is and it's in part because she
doesn't have a lot of illusions because
she sees reality as rather unvarnished
although she's probably projecting the
the hostility that she feels towards
others onto others and receiving it back
she's the one who is immediately able to
say here's the problem here's the trap
that were stuck in we're gonna be
torturing each other yeah you know when
they say no no I won't be I won't be
doing that sort of thing she says well I
will and I bet you you will too because
you're not as good as you think and
after a little while with me you're
probably gonna want to torture me back
to at the same time there is one moment
we're late on in the play she trusted
gar Sanna about something and perhaps
she's just sort of putting on you know
she's just engaging in a argumentative
move but perhaps she really is showing a
moment of real vulnerability where
Garcia has promised that he will help
her now she's you know sort of thrown
that back in his face and then he
responds to Estelle who who's trying to
seduce him for her own ends and says I'm
gonna go along with this and she says
you promised me you promised and he says
well you went back on your promise first
there is the one moment where she
here's to be really hurt to the core all
the rest of the time she's more or less
frustrated and disgusted she would like
to have Estella all to herself and she
sort of thinks that were Garr cent not
in the picture she could eventually
bring a stella round probably not the
case given that they're they're in hell
but that's one of the things that that's
motivating her she admits that she
herself is a coward when garça says you
you know you and I have something in
common so what we've got here
Eden as is somebody who has many fewer
illusions than the other two but as many
fewer illusions because she recognizes
just what a a bastard she is the third
main character comes in not long after
the other two and her name is Estelle
rego and she comes in very worried that
that she's going to have to confront her
her ex-lover who had apparently shot
himself in the face yeah and she's
surprised to find out that no she's in
with these other two who she has
seemingly nothing in common with at all
what can we say about her well she is in
a certain respect a rags to riches story
through marrying an older man and it's
worth sort of spending a little bit of
time that part of her story she says
this early on she says I lost my parents
when I was a kid and I had my young
brother to bring up we were terribly
poor and when an old friend of my people
asked me to marry him I said yes he was
very well-off and quite nice my brother
was a very delicate child and needed all
sorts of attention so really that was
the right thing for me to do don't you
agree my husband was old enough to be my
father but for six years we had a happy
married life then two years ago I met
the man I was fated to love we knew at
the moment we set eyes on each other he
asked me to run away with him an IRA
used that I got pneumonia and it
finished me that's the whole story
no doubt by certain standards I did
wrong to sacrifice my youth youth to a
man nearly three times my age do you
think that could be called a sin and
what's interesting about this is that it
shows that she's from the beginning
telling a story that's that's plausible
because it has some elements that are
actually truthful but it's it's
superficial it's not actually getting at
what her real motives were what the not
even the real facts she's leaving out
some very important facts that are gonna
surface a bit later you know there's
more of the story because you know she's
worried about seeing somebody who's shot
his face off when she comes in but she's
telling this very genteel you know
another term that I should put in here
and she she's kind of not only
superficial but she's also and I'm gonna
use the word pseudo here
she's a pseudo romantic she would like
everything to be nice and lovey-dovey
and for her to be the center of
courtship and attention and she tells
this story about the self-sacrificing
heroine who you know to take care of her
her young sick brother marries a man
who's much older but even then you know
it's it's still good for six years they
love each other but then she meets the
man who you know it was in the stars her
to cross paths with and and to love even
though he you know she was already
married to somebody else and she uses
this kind of romanticism to justify her
choices to do the wrong thing to cheat
to deceive and we're gonna see this
what's going on with with her is
gradually all of this is sort of peeled
away and it's peeled away in a different
way than it is with with Garson with
garça it's his own sort of questioning
the corrosiveness of his own reflection
aided by an as
to a lesser extent by Estelle that tears
away the illusions
he's already worried himself about
whether he's doing the right thing
Estelle is somebody who almost perfectly
exemplifies what Sartre calls bad faith
she could be the woman who he describes
and being in nothingness who goes out on
a date knowing full well that the guy's
gonna expect her to put out at the end
of the date and doesn't want to think
about that wants to think he's really a
nice guy and you know the guy takes her
hand and she doesn't quite commit to her
hand being in his hand because that
would mean that she knows where this is
going but she doesn't pull it away
either because that would also apply
that she knows where it's going and said
she just kind of leaves it there
neutrally unless things happen until
they get to the point of you know no
return and which gate at which point she
can say I didn't know what to do my hand
was forced Estelle is that kind of
person and yet at the same time she is
acting she is choosing she's actually in
many respects quite manipulative but
disguises this from herself so she
represents a certain character type you
might say she cheated on her husband we
find that out early on it's only with
with a bit more time in where they start
stripping away the the blinds that we
find out that she actually killed her
baby daughter
that's why she's she's in hell not just
for you know not for making the mistake
of marrying not for love and you know to
take care of her her brother and not
just because she cheated on her husband
but because she killed her own daughter
who is the result of that that affair
and they questioned her they say well
you're down here because you had this
affair and she says that's not it
finally she says you've got it all wrong
you too he wanted me to have a baby they
were saying you didn't
be with him because he was poor and you
know he killed himself because you
wouldn't be with him she says no he
wanted me to have a baby
and garces's and you didn't want one and
then she says I certainly didn't but the
baby came worst luck I went to
Switzerland for five months no one knew
anything it was a girl Roger Roger was
with me when she was born it pleased him
to know and having a daughter it didn't
please me so the man who she's cheating
with is delighted that they've had this
baby together
and you could imagine all sorts of
circumstances or maybe he takes the
child and goes lost somewhere instead
I'll tell you her in her own words there
was a balcony overlooking the lake I
brought a big stone he could see what I
was up to and kept on shouting Estella
for God's sake don't I hated him that he
saw it all he was leaning over the
balcony and he saw the Rings spreading
out on the water I think our son says
yes and then I now notice there's no
remorse there whatsoever there's no
sense that something horrible has
happened she says I came back to Paris
and he did as he wished and what he
wished was to kill himself after that
yeah and he says garces's you mean he
blew his brains out and Estelle says it
was absurd of him really my husband
never suspected anything and what this
shows is that she's still not getting it
she created a child with this man kills
the child and then her only view on it
is the child was sort of an exposition
of the fact that that she cheated and so
now that the child is gone
everything should be a-okay and there
was no reason for him to kill himself
why should he have felt that so she's
she's really not not getting it and a
certain way she she may deserve to be
there more than them because of the the
degree of self-deception that she's
involved
another thing that is absolutely central
to her character and part of why the
play actually works is because estelle
exists in the gaze and the desire of
others primarily men and there's an
early sort of flirtation that's taking
place with an ends which is part of why
and Nez is actually going to be so so so
upset this is part of the trap that's
being laid for a Nez and she she hasn't
she says tuned as that she exists in the
eyes of others and Nez offers her a
mirror this is early on and there we go
this is after they're supposed to be
being quiet she yeah here we go
she asks do you have a mirror and an ass
says I think I do in my purse so she
checks but she doesn't
so she says come on over here I'll be
your mirror and she ends up telling the
stell that you know her makeup is a bit
off and she likes it that way all of
those those sorts of things I'm not
finding the exact passive so I'll have
to sort of summarize it Wow here we go
she says - and Nez I feel so strange
don't you ever get taken that way when I
can't see myself I begin to wonder if I
really and truly exist I Pat myself just
to make sure but it doesn't help much
and
and now says I don't have that problem I
can't do it from my existence I know
what I what I'm like I'm always
conscious of myself in my mind painfully
conscious and Garson will probably say
the same thing and Estelle says yes in
your mind but everything goes off that
goes out in one's head is so vague isn't
it it makes one want to sleep I've got
six big mirrors in my bedroom there they
are I can see them but they don't see me
they're reflecting the carpet the settee
the window now empty it is a glass in
which I am absence so what you've got
here is somebody who knows that she
exists and knows what she what she is
only when it's being mirrored back to
her she needs the other to tell her what
she is and how she is
she says somehow it kept me alert seeing
myself as the others saw me without that
she can't really be sure what she's like
she says and has the answer am I not
nicer than your glass Anna stillson's by
now you really scare me rather my
reflection in the glass never did that
of course I knew it so well like
something I obtained so what what a
stone really wants is to be surrounded
by others and by others who satisfy the
kinds of desires that she has one of the
most basic of which is a rather
narcissistic desire to be seen to be
affirmed
and she'll talk about this a little bit
later on when she's able to see this
this young man who she didn't have an
affair with but was sort of leading on
and he's dancing with this this other
woman who was friends with her and him
and she her name is Olga and he says
they're dancing together she can see
what's going on and he says Vanessa
who's Peter and Estelle says such a
silly boy called me his glancing stream
just
he was terribly in love with me she's
persuaded him to come out with her
tonight and why does this bother Estelle
she says he belonged to me I had
captivated him she exists in the gaze
not just the gaze but the desire of
others primarily men this is why she's
such a frustration for an S because she
says and as you don't count you don't
matter
you're nothing because you can't give me
what I want that guy over there though
he sure can and a little bit later on
when he is you know going through his
qualms about am ia coward she says there
he also says Estelle you must give me
your trust he's looking for a sort of
spiritual connection to her she says oh
what a nuisance you are I'm giving you
my mouth my arms my whole body and
everything could be so simple my trust
I haven't any to give I'm afraid of
you're making me terribly embarrassed
why can't we just exist you know and be
involved with this on the physical level
don't you desire me just shut up and
let's you know do what we're going to do
and eventually and he goes through his
whole discussion of am i coward am I not
a coward
and that says Estelle do you like
cowards and she says if you knew how
little I care
coward her hero it's all one provided he
kisses well a little bit later as it
turns out that that she was kind of
joking about that but she really does
have a sort of indifference about this
she says I'd love you just the same even
if you were a coward isn't that enough
she also says to him you know you don't
really have a coward's face or a college
voice and that's enough for me
so this is her her character she is you
know she's not a sexpot she's not just
motivated by buts
really she doesn't actually designer him
so much he has to be desired by him and
to reduce everything to that level where
she knows that she exists where
paradoxically it's safer for her she's
in a certain way even more damaged than
in DES org our Santa Ynez uses the
language of traps booby traps
specifically and Garcia uses the
language of a spider's web and both of
these are actually apt for the situation
that all three of these characters are
placed with them and the traps exist not
just within the structure of the room
itself but within each other and the
structures of their desires their
attitudes what it is that they've
brought into the room with them there's
a number of solutions sort of escape
routes that gets sketched out mostly by
car sin as a matter of fact it may be
stretching it a bit to say that number
five which is proposed by n as disease
actually escape routes more in just a
modus vivendi a way of living together
that she proposes one which of course
he's not going to be able to find
acceptable and over and over and over
again what happens is one of these is
proposed and the people to whom they're
proposed it's mostly Garth's and doing
the proposing will not be able to live
with it will say no I can't I can't
that's not what I want to do at all and
so over and over each of the possible
ways of making the situation not quite
so bad or even changing the situation
later on with some of the proposals that
Vaqueros making they're not going to
work you know this as well that I don't
have Estelle's proposed solution which
is just that she and gar sash would
essentially get it on because it doesn't
seem like she conceives of that
as you know and the way that car saying
is is the way out of hell it's just in a
certain way to pass the time
or to make things work for this moment
so let's look at each of these in turn
the first one is just between your sad
and in nads when they show when they
both are in the room together before
Estelle shows up and Garson proposes to
her if I may venture on a suggestion we
should make a point of being extremely
courteous to each other this will ease
the situation for us both and an SS I'm
not polite and then garces's then I must
be polite for two so it seems like he's
bending over backwards to make this work
and then the next thing in ed says is
your mouth so I beg your pardon
can't you keep your mouth still you keep
twisting it about all the time it's
grotesque and then she says that's what
I didn't reproach you with there you are
you talk about politeness and you don't
even try to control your face remember
you're not alone you've no right to
inflict the sight of your fear on me so
that's not going to work
garça can try to be courteous but what
looks like courteousness in his eyes
does not look so in a neces eyes and she
undermines it anyway in part because of
the cruelty that she exhibits the second
one is a bit more developed as a
proposals and Garcelle suggests once an
N says here's the situation where we're
gonna be torturous to each other
she says he says the solution is easy
enough each of us stays put in his or
her corner and takes no notice of the
others you hear you hear and I they're
like soldiers and our posts also we
mustn't speak not one word that won't be
difficult each of us has plenty of
material for self-communing I could
think I could stay ten thousand years
with only my thoughts for company
yeah and Estelle says have I got to be
silent too and he says yes yeah then
that way we will work on our salvation
looking into ourselves never raising our
hands agreed in an S says agreed and
this to us is a I agree innocence then
goodbye and almost immediately and
and starts singing to herself Estelle
starts doing her makeup yeah and the
ways in which they are communing with
themselves turned out to be ways that
are going to impinge upon the others in
particular Estelle ends up asking I wish
I had a mirror do you have a mirror and
they started having this conversation
back and forth that flirtation that I
talked about earlier
and unfortunately Garson can not get
away from that you know he says I asked
you to leave me in peace
and and you know I begged you not to
speak and it didn't work a little bit
later he says for Kitty's sake keep your
mouth shut
let's all sit down again quite quietly
we'll look at the floor and you see each
must try to forget the others are here
and this is where Ann as says that that
famous set of lines that I mentioned
earlier to forget about the others
how utterly absurd I feel you there in
every pore your silence clamors in my
ears you can nail up your mouth cut your
tongue out but you can't prevent your
being there can you stop your thoughts
I hear them ticking away like a clock
tick tock tick tock and I'm certain you
can hear mine it's all very well
skulking on your sofa but you're
everywhere and every sound comes to me
soiled because you're you've intercepted
it on its way you even install in my
face you know it and I don't I won't
leave you at peace she says so why won't
she leave him in peace because even when
he is proposing it we're each gonna like
have our own little corners that's not
gonna work human presence doesn't work
that way and for search human presence
is always going to be viewed as kind of
a threat as as an encumbrance to others
so then Garson flips the scales and he
says fine
have it your way I suppose we were bound
to come to this they knew what they are
about and that we're easy game they just
put me in a room with men men who keep
their mouths shut
but I'm stuck here with you so let's be
now
trol and then he says do you know I used
to be mad about women and some were fond
of me so we may as well stop posing we
have nothing to lose why trouble about
politeness and decorum and the rest of
us we're between ourselves and presently
and we shall be naked as newborn babes
and so this is where the the revelations
go yeah they start you know sort of
tearing down some of the the veils about
who they are and why that are there and
you know it doesn't make sense maybe
that'll make us a better able to live
with each other but that's precisely
what reveals to them how hellish the
existence with these other people are
each of them realizes the others can see
them for what they are and they don't
like that and they're also seeing the
others for the disgusting people that
they are in turn Garcelle strangely
enough proposes they should help each
other this is the fourth solution he
says I suppose we start trying to help
each other and I know says I don't need
help
Garson says and as they've laid their
snare damn cunningly like a cobweb if
you make any movement if you raise your
hand to fan yourself
estelle and I feel a little tongue alone
none of us can save himself or herself
we're linked together inextricably so
you can take your choice so really what
he's talking about there is something
like solidarity we're all in this
together we all need to think about how
we're going to help ourselves and at the
same time help each other out of this
situation
and that doesn't work either and as yes
what do you expect me to do in return
and garces's to help me all it takes is
a little effort you know as just a spark
of human feeling and then she says human
feeling that's beyond my range I'm
rotten to the core
so unless all three of them are willing
to help each other it's not going to
work and they're not it nez makes it
clear that she has pulled out of that
possible solution
she proposes at a certain point
Garson if you just butt out you want to
be by yourself
go ahead leave me and the girl alone and
we'll work out what we're gonna do
she says keep your pity for yourself
don't forget Garson there are traps for
you too in this room all nicely set for
you you'd do better to watch your own
interests but if you will leave us in
peace this child in me I'll see I don't
do you any harm so what she's proposing
is something like a truce like if he can
stay over there and not interfere the
the dynamic between the two of them that
she will not tear into him she will
refrain from that that doesn't work
either
finally there's two interesting
solutions proposed by Bart by Carson
first to Estelle and then to and Ness he
proposes to Estelle who is you know
trying to essentially seduce him and to
arouse his desire for her he says don't
shrink away listen I want you to do me a
service I know that it must seem strange
to you having somebody asks you for help
you're not used to that but if you make
the effort if you only will it hard
enough I date I daresay we can really
love each other so love can be the way
out of hell look at it this way a
thousand of them are proclaiming on a
coward but what a numbers matter if
there's someone just one person to say
quite positively I did not run away that
I'm not the sort who runs away that I'm
brave and decent to the rest of it that
one person's faith so it's really not
love faith what saved me well you have
that faith in me then I shall love and
cherish you forever Estelle will you and
Estelle says oh you silly man
do you think I could love a coward it's
too late she can't have that sort of
faith in Him because he's revealed to
her that he isn't coming and she says
you know you don't have a coward's chin
or a coward's mouth
and it's that stuff that I love about
you but by love she just means she wants
him to desire her and she desires him
and he says do you mean this really mean
it
and he said she says shall I swear it
and Garson getting very optimistic says
then I snap my fingers at them all those
below and those in here Estelle we shall
climb out of hell and announce last and
he says what's that
and that says she doesn't mean a word of
what she says how can you be such a
simpleton
Estelle am ia coward as if she cared a
damn either way and then she lets it you
know down she says what do you expect me
to say don't you realize how maddening
it is to have to answer questions one
can't make Matt can't make head or tail
of she literally can't see what it is
that Garson is driving at with all this
talk about love and faith and then she's
she's at a lower level you could say
spiritually and she's not really ready
for that the last one after after Garson
has gone through this long sort of
seduction passage and anaz and all of
them haven't had a big fight they
actually try to throw it nez out of the
the the door because the door opens yeah
Garson won't allow Estelle to push her
out why not because he says I need an S
because the nazan me actually have a lot
more in common
he says it's you who I have to convince
you are of my kind did you suppose I
meant to go no I couldn't leave you here
gloating over my defeat with all those
thoughts about me running in your head
and in essence you you're gonna try to
convince me that you're not a coward and
he says I've got all eternity to
convince you that's the one and only
thing I wish for now it's you who
matters you who hate me if you have
faith in me I'm saved and in essence
that's not gonna be easy
I don't like you as a matter of fact I
do hate you I think you're a coward and
I'm a hard-headed woman and he says I'll
give
all the time that's needed and he says
this is something really important to me
I want to do this and you know she tears
him down a bit more at that point and
she says keep at it it shouldn't be so
hard convincing me pull yourself
together man rake up some arguments now
you're going to pay the price I'm really
nothing I'm just mere breath on the air
and yet you can't get out of me what it
is that you're desire so all of these
solutions all of these attempts to get
out of help break down and this leads us
to the conclusion that L is other people
and really in order for it to work for
start you need several people all of
whom can confuse can stymie each other's
desires their self images who can you
know refuse each other
who can use their freedom in such a way
as to interfere with the freedom of the
other person who can tear the other
person down and so it's impossible to
attain any sort of stable solution if
these two line up together and say we're
going to you know be a team against you
they're stuck still in the presence of
this other person and Sartre in his
philosophy seems to be saying yes that's
actually the human condition we're
always whether we realize it or not
stuck in this this condition of having
to deal with alien freedom having to
deal with the the freedom the choice the
way of looking at things of others not
being able to convince them not
truly being sure of ourselves and so the
hell that he's describing you might
think of it as sort of penetrating
further outward into the world of our
own experience this is a very dim view
of things not all existentialist see it
this way but this is particularly and
peculiarly Sartre in' and so this is why
to bring this to a conclusion
no exit is such an important and
emblematic piece of Sartre in literature